let's talk about Dark Souls 3 cool so
our review for dark souls 3 your review
the Dark Souls 3 when top was a couple
days ago yes yes midnight yesterday yeah
yesterday early morning cool enter town
on gamespot com you've been playing a
bunch of it and yeah the office for the
past while we've had you on to talk
about it in vague terms yes I mean Mary
and Erica were playing at a bunch as
well so it's been chat around the office
for a little while now sham ate at a 10
so I guess we got a bunch questions for
you from from the game spot audience but
why do you sort of main takeaways from
Doc so where does this fit in terms of
the quality of previous games where does
it fit in terms of a game Dark Souls
game coming in 2016 when everyone kind
of knows what the format is then sure
it's actually really good this is
probably a question but it's probably a
good entry point for someone all right
spite the fact that it's the third game
and the what I think is gonna be a
trilogy when I'm pretty sure is going to
be it's a great game I was you know it
was it was bordering on being at nine
for me but the more I played it and got
into the late game the more it kind of
lost its momentum for me and its
creativity that the rest of the game
displayed so well and I love dark souls
I love demon's souls blood-borne it just
those there are certain games like Dark
Souls 1 and blood-borne do such a good
job of pushing you through the endgame
and kind of making your progress up to
that point worth it and there's still
very much worth it in Dark Souls 3 but
it didn't really have that kind of
climax and then really like engaging
late game hours that I've come to expect
from the series as something you were
highlighting was something i was talking
to eric about last week as well which is
that there's a decent amount of
repetition when it comes to bosses in
terms of their like move sets at least
well yeah I mean yeah I think I said
redundant bosses because they're all
kind of repetitive in a way like when
you start fighting them enough times I
think the most one boss took me was
eight tries mmm so guy named pontiff's
Sullivan if I'm pronouncing that
correctly but yeah there were not
Sullivan yeah I was gonna say no there's
something I try to like lend a little
medieval flared all these ice a fair
enough yeah like in tiffs 1111 and no
but some there were about three or four
bosses later in the game one of which is
that one of the main bosses you're
hunting down one of the Lords of cinder
as they call it and i was playing them
and i realized i'm using the same exact
strategy
I used against this boss the second boss
of the game or the fourth boss of the
game or the first boss the game and
they're all still really there well
designed boss fights but really heavy
deja vu kicked in while I was fighting
them and they're like oh I'm just
staying between this one's legs which
you know you play earlier Dark Souls you
do that with a lot of the bigger bosses
and a lot of the bosses who kind of
thrive on the those sweeping attacks
like the 360 so that to kind of keep it
off their side but you know I you start
playing these bosses and you would like
to see some more creative Liberty later
on the game but it doesn't it feels like
they kind of I mean I'm not evaluating
their intentions but it feels like it
kind of the game feels fatigued after a
while because you know I'm repeating
something I've done earlier despite the
fact that my characters gotten better
I've gotten better I've learned a lot
since I fought that boss for hours in as
opposed to 20 where I am now and that
kind of I didn't feel cheated because it
was still it's still really fun and
there's still a huge award and killing
that boss but it's still at that point I
I wanted the game to reflect the
progress i had made yeah because that's
the alluring thing of Dark Souls told me
that's what it did the whole point of
the series of the thing that people love
about it then watch is that it respects
the player sharing like teaches that
like requires them requires quite a lot
of them in terms of skills so if you're
saying that the end of the game sort of
founders not respect and yeah that's got
to be a bummer sure except for like the
last two bosses are really great ones
pretty you know that spoiling too much
the last boss doesn't do anything
completely new it's definitely a fun
boss and it was it's well worth it
definitely makes sense to have as a last
boss unless you do you know barring any
optional bosses of which there are a
bunch but the last like boss in the main
story is also it's pretty creative in
terms of how you fight it so yeah there
are there are some really bright points
later in the game but not enough to
really kind of push me through as much
as like blood-borne or dark souls 1 or
demon souls did real killer 7 8 9 says
the formula for the game hasn't changed
a lot I kinda want to talk to both you
about this you know the original Dark
Soul Argost you could say demon souls
are dark souls and to a certain extent
blood-borne these are games that you
know where we're doing something new or
at least doing something new for a new
audience and obviously that's something
that haces reviewer is really like a
last one or you know we play a lot of
games when something there's something
new I think we've rated very highly and
so does the audience like people like
when they're surprised in a new way
and obviously Dark Souls did that in the
past I'll ask you first of all Peter do
you think that makes a big difference
for a reviewer when now we're talking
about you know it's the third Dark Souls
game but we've had two missiles in the
past and blood-borne they exist within
this sort of group of games that sort of
trick doesn't ring as true you know it's
not as interesting as you know this far
down the line surely right it can't
contribute as much to a wonderful you
know game review because we kind of know
that trick is it's coming for the most
part when we're reviewing a game that's
further down the line in a series we
find someone to review it who has
experience and and that's because we
want them to have a discussion that is
well-informed not to necessarily prop
the game up against somebody who's going
to recognize what hasn't changed that
said whether or not that's important is
down to the individual who's writing the
review yeah I mean I feel like this has
come to my table when it comes like fifa
and f1 yeah in that there are like games
that do the same thing every year right
and they do a well maybe they don't do
enough and maybe they do do enough and
it's kind of difficult to depart I mean
my biggest criticism of assassin seeds
indicators that like oh yeah it's a get
that somebody would really love this
game but for me I feel burnt out on this
series so that's the reason I would
personally rate it solo yeah and that's
in subjectivity is very important yeah
so what do you think about this rule
does our were you happy enough just to
play another duck so i know and i want
to say as well it is weird that we're
talking about this we gave the game a
[ __ ] it at a time because that's a
really good review but there is this
weird sort of backlash or you know sort
of that idea on the internet that's not
my eyes aren't school grades yeah yeah
50 or 60 is not failing yeah sure so
what do you think about that in terms of
you playing it subjectively did this
game do enough for you as a duck sauce
on would you been willing to play
another Dark Souls 2 uh well that's the
thing I think Pete and I had the
discussion yesterday afternoon or
something and he said yeah reading a
review i got like half way through it
and I just thinking to myself well this
could just be any Dark Souls game you're
reviewing right now right but then you
get toward the end of my review and that
was my point Dark Souls 3 despite a lot
of the things that they've been kind of
touting is new it doesn't do that much
new the main new things I saw was in its
structure and how you go throughout its
world and how that kind of fact
is in I mean there there's the the new
FP bar which dictates it's your mat but
it's essentially a mana pool for your
weapon arts and that was kind of an
afterthought for me every once in a
while I would use them and they are
helpful but it didn't really factor into
how I was fighting blood-borne has
seeped into this a little bit i think i
described this as if as if Dark Souls 1
and blood-borne had a baby that were
dark souls 3 yeah yeah that'd be a
grotesque looking jay jaffe blood-borne
indeed and I'm sorry it doesn't it
doesn't do the same thing for me that
Dark Souls 1 did I think I still think
dark souls 1 like even looking back now
Dark Souls 1 i think is still the best
in the series despite the fact like even
removing any you know novelty from it
like now that we're on three it might
just be that i'm tired of the series i'm
really not i mean blood-borne was is you
know it's not the same series but it
does so many great new things and it I'm
more excited for a blood-borne to now
than after playing dark souls oh really
yeah but dark souls 1 I mean I can't I
actually just started a new game the
other day because it came with like the
retail copy of Dark Souls 3 and it still
does so many things better than two and
three um I think three is like my third
favorite I think if I had to rank him
it'd be like Dark Souls blood-borne
demon's souls actually which is still a
great game 3 and then too not that I
dislike to but yeah I think in hindsight
it's weird looking back at one cuz
usually like you said on the third of a
trilogy they have to kind of try to keep
the momentum going as you them however
they can i still think one holds up
better than any of them yeah it's it's a
great game and you know it three a big
thing with reviewing sequels how is it
different I don't think three is largely
that different than the other ones yeah
and that's not that doesn't make it a
bad game it's still it's a great game
I'm I'd be very surprised if we got to
the end of 2016 it's not my top 10 cool
um but yeah I just didn't I didn't I
don't think I did anything really
special like the other ones did no
worries I got a bunch of questions here
about a hero the top and a bunch of
other people asking general crisis by
frame rates platform to play on all that
sort of stuff yeah how does it look
across the older platforms which one
sort of runs the best I me as you can
imagine it run it looks better on like a
nice pc it looks good on all of them the
framerate issues there were some and
they it did pretty low but it was never
at a time
I actually it affected the game the
first spot I noticed it is when after
you're approaching this boss and you
kind of their strong hints that you're
about to go up against the boss so I
tried to backtrack to the previous
bonfire and the game does this thing
we're just a bunch of these skeletons
rise up and create like something like
30 skeletons and then the frame rate
dropped but I was wasn't really near
them you could just tell the game was
chugging alright so that didn't really
affect it too much there's definitely I
think it runs a little better on pc from
what I've seen they did say there was a
day one patch or patch incoming that
supposedly is gonna fix them and I want
to jump back in yeah I don't think it's
gonna really affect my review but the
frame rate dips never really affected me
I know two more and UK is playing and I
don't think he knows saying anything
severe although I am seeing other
reviewers that had problems with it mmm
and yeah that's tough because I don't
know I didn't really affect me
personally which I'm grateful for but if
the game isn't running smoothly that
sucks but yeah it's a pc is pcs looks
great runs well it's not locked at 30
frames like the consoles are but the
console is still ran smoothly for me
cool awesome so it feels like we've had
this in the office forever is it
actually at today or is that next week
no it's out yeah tuesday tuesday 12 next
week are awesome